a California man suspected of targeting
police during a two-day crime spree is
dead after a manhunt ended with a
shootout police say 26 year-old Mason
Lehrer shot a deputy and killed a
homeless man Wednesday then wounded
three more officers yesterday before he
was shot and killed Jonathan Vigliotti
has been following this in Paso Robles
California Jonathan any word on a motive
yeah Vlad good morning to you the
sheriff says there is no doubt this was
an ambush but at this point the exact
motive is unclear that manhunt came to
an end in this vineyard the suspects
father saying that he had schizophrenia
and was living in a fantasy world the
suspect was shot that announcement came
after law enforcement swarmed the
streets and the sky in Paso Robles
closing in on Mason Lehrer and killing
him in a shootout Thursday unusual
frightening this is unreal that he's
brought it to this town Vera's shooting
spree began Wednesday morning when he
shot sheriff's deputy Nicholas Dreyfus
in the head outside the police station
and fled the scene Dreyfus is expected
to recover
just blocks away police found the body
of a dead homeless man with a single
gunshot to the head
they suspect Lehrer was the killer a
manhunt ensued as officers scoured
surrounding neighborhoods and after
Lehrer was seen at a gas station early
Thursday by around 2:00 p.m. police
received another report of an officer
shot two hours later gunfire erupted
between Lehrer and police officers hit
and lehre killed in the crossfire
Liras father told The Associated Press
his son had schizophrenia Asperger's
syndrome and ADHD but refused to take
his medication and sometimes believed
himself to be a special agent or soldier
and a report by the san luis obispo
tribune revealed Lehrer posted several
odd writings and photographs of guns to
his now-deleted Facebook page do you
think this was a random attack or a
targeted attack against law enforcement
oh I have no doubt it was targeted and
intended to to kill law enforcement
Lehrer was recently arrested for making
criminal threats that happened about two
hours north of here in Monterey he was
released from jail just last week kale
Jonathan thank you very much very glad
that officer has survived